there's three or four of them you know
why why would you do this to me
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by andrew zimmern
he's a chef restaurateur author and emmy
award winning food tv pioneer you can
catch his latest series family dinner
with andrew zimmern sunday nights on
magnolia network with wild game kitchen
coming later this year to outdoor
channel but today the man who's eating
his way through the world's most
remarkable and curious cuisines tries
his hand at the hot ones gauntlet andrew
zimmern welcome to the show it's long
overdue it's i'm giddy with excitement
and i'm actually uh being very truthful
about that i've wanted to do this for a
long time
so it's great to finally be here with
you
[Music]
i'm assuming uh starting in the far
right we're right in front of that
all right
[Music]
that's delicious
i'm not just a hot one's guest i'm also
a customer
i think i've purchased that one from you
guys
love it love it love it so when we had
adam richmond on the show he talked
about a picture of you him and anthony
bourdain that was captioned the gang of
three and i'm curious how do you
contextualize that era of travel channel
shows and ultimately the influence that
they've had over the years
tony's first season
had just completed airing when my first
season uh
started to roll out so in what was his
second season in my first we did a
crossover episode which is to me one of
the greatest 90 minutes of television
i've ever participated in
that was the golden age of that network
regardless of what day of the week that
you were tuning in there were really
really really immersive travelers taking
you into all kinds of really cool places
but i think what
when adam talks about about that he he
talks about three big hits you know with
with tony show my show and adam show man
versus food that for a very small
network relative to others on cable was
you know had three big big shows going
on at the same time that audience
responded to
and now of course they're
it's ghost and paranormal on travel
channel they it's not even it's turtle
trvl
they had a vowel movement
[Music]
it comes up it's that's balanced
even if you happen to love garlic i mean
a lot of that processed stuff that sits
there in soybean oil that was chopped
two years ago and pasteurized that winds
up in a lot of foods because it's less
expensive is the least appealing garlic
flavor that i can think of but that's
that's really
wonderful
so i probably spent almost as much time
watching bizarre foods on travel channel
in college as i did at cam's happy hour
what's your favorite bizarre foods
concoction from the minnesota state fair
i'm super boring that way cheese curds a
really good foot long and a natural skin
that snaps when you bite into it
best french fries uh in america are at
the french fry booth at the minnesota
state fair so i'm a classicist
when it comes to state fair foods uh
although i did have
this thing called like a cloud roll or a
rainbow cloud roll and what it was it
was rainbow colored cotton candy and
they put sherbet down
rainbow sherbet or rainbow ice cream or
rainbow gelato i've seen it all
different ways in the middle and then
they sprinkle it with fruity pebbles and
then they roll it up the way they do you
know those a commercial burrito place or
that oversized burrito and you see the
purse just like stuff i mean they're
manhandling that thing to get it big i
mean they really work it
that's how they do it with the cotton
candy and it compresses it and i've
eaten that i thought to myself
i'm going to take one bite and throw it
it's just going to be too sweet there's
no way this is going to be good but
there's something about the cold
quiescently frozen dessert treat in the
middle part that gets me every time i
love it
just one more bite just one more just
one just one more bite yes you can just
feel the
number this one
bark and hopkins
with sun-dried tomato
all right
[Music]
wow
that's good
so you've always had a crystal ball when
it comes to the evolution of how we eat
and i'm fascinated by how food trends
actually pick up steam what are the key
contributing factors that cause things
like filipino barbecue or birya tacos to
all of a sudden gain all this mainstream
attention even though these things are
not exactly new social media people go
absolutely nuts for certain things when
they see it and chefs have been well
food lovers geeks like me you have been
talking about charred pepperoni cups
forever right i mean i don't i don't
want flat
you know
food service
pepperoni that just lays flaccidly on
the pizza
bakes and just kicks off a bunch of you
know
ill-tasting oil that's not my idea of
pepperoni i want good pepperoni small
cut thick enough so it curls up in
little cups that char and that flavor is
incredible on pizza but it wasn't until
people started posting pictures of that
that you know
kids in small towns in the midwest were
like where's my charred pepperoni cups
right and i know because i had a small
kid in the midwest who said where's my
pepperoni cups and eventually
a neapolitan style pizza place opened
that did it that way and he loved it
right and it changed his life forever
but where he first saw it was pictures
on websites and on my phone and i think
that's the power that we're forgetting
about these days
[Music]
cantaloupe melon oh scotch bonnet
fantastic my favorite chili
not just because it's spicy
but because it has a very unique flavor
[Music]
so recently did a first wee feast
episode of snack and had something
interesting to say about how visiting a
supermarket can tell you more about a
place than visiting its museums how do
you navigate supermarkets when you
travel abroad and what does a country's
snack selection say about its culture if
you go into another country and you
don't spend 20 minutes in a supermarket
i think you're making a mistake it's
like go to a [ __ ] supermarket look at
what other people are eating see look at
the prices you want to understand
reykjavik you want to understand iceland
go into a supermarket and see that
carrots are 25 a pound but lamb is free
okay
dried fish buck a pound broccoli 24 a
bite i mean i'm exaggerating to make a
point right but that tells you all you
need to know about what's going on
iceland and food
and how this cycle of
food plays in our life and if you go
into a supermarket and you look at what
people snack on you can learn a hell of
a lot
all right los calientes los calientes
rojo is the next one yeah why do they
have a verde or a
as a matter or just like saying rojo as
a matter of fact we do we have a faraday
we have a barbacoa
oh
that's just delicious
what kind of chilies are in this one
we got some smoked jalapeno in this one
habanero and this one
i was just gonna say i love the
sweetness it's apricot is the third
ingredient yeah yeah yeah see that's
super smart cooking
right there
i would pour this on anything not drip
it
all right
thank you so much let me ask you a
question sure whatever you want cause
you probably know this better than most
people
what the [ __ ] is it with people that
they put a little plastic thing with
another hole in it inside every bottle
of everything
well you know not just hot stuff catch
up all the rest but i mean like you're
in this world
so we don't put a stopper on ours and
that includes this one the last ab
apollo we don't put a stopper on that
but sometimes what i find myself doing
is just basically dumping half a bottle
because we don't have that stopper on
accident and sometimes i'm like we need
a stopper on this one you know we
haven't gotten to that point that's the
technical term in the bottle business so
yeah
this this this is just the first we
feast way we just make it up as we go
but i always think with this one maybe
we need to stop her but the other ones
well i understand it was something sort
of if you can't work your elbow or
shoulder like i get it but everyone else
should just you know put on their adult
pants and
let us rock yeah all right andrew every
current segment on our show called
explain that grammar we do a deep dive
on our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
so we'll pull the picture up over here
on the monitor i was just trying to
escape this the bigger story you can't
all right you can't escape
what is it that you find sacred about
disc golf and then do you have any tips
for beginners just grab some friends go
out there and do it disc golfers on the
course love to share wisdom with other
disc golfers and just like cooking you
can go online and just google disc golf
and forehand backhand putting and give
yourself a lesson and carry it with you
on your phone and say is this how i
stand and then you know
you know do it um
i mean this is pretty personal but 30
years ago i was you know i had been a
homeless street grifter and addict and
alcoholic and when i'm out there on the
course
like cooking i'm not thinking about my
problems and my life and the issues at
work and stuff in
you know going on my friends whatever it
is that we obsess about at least i'm
just focused on
throwing my backhand the right way
and uh i look kind of buff in that
picture yeah it's a good looking picture
that is a good i look like i have really
big arms and i work out it's about
trying new things and if i had to tell
people
one thing in their lives just maybe
having lived a few more years than other
folks it's like try new things it's one
of the things i was trying to do with
bizarre foods was get move people out of
their comfort zone i don't think someone
is going to go down to west virginia and
start hammering down squirrel brains i
mean that's i i get it you're not gonna
do that but maybe if you're down there
and someone has you know fried squirrel
on the menu you may say look sure i'll
try that and then you go you know
something that's pretty good and maybe
you'll take a risk then with something
else in your life that's maybe even more
meaningful than sharing a meal
oh
all right that works
oh really good
that fermented bean
that flavor pairs very well with the
heat
whereas sweetened chocolate wouldn't my
opinion
i agree with you there
in recent years you've done a lot to
push congress on food policy
particularly when it comes to feeding
hungry kids and issues involving food
waste what's an issue that never comes
up in the debates that people who love
and care about food should think about
more when they vote locally are we are
we actually in this country voting for
keeping children hungry because with no
national school lunch program that's
free for any student that needs it
that food that runs 12 months a year
right where any child can get a meal
that's that's beyond criminal that's
genocidal and it and it's genocidal
because we have the ability to do it we
just don't have the will to do it we
have the money for it it's actually not
that expensive
we can do this we can statistically
eliminate hunger tomorrow in america if
we chose to
i think it's vitally important that
people understand that
climate affects food and our food
choices are affecting
our climate right
food choices for
keeping cheap meat has created these you
know kafo farms and all the
animal dung that goes up contributes to
greenhouse gases and the the runoff from
these horrific chemicals that are used
on animals and on the ground uh it gets
into our water system and
causes havoc further
down the food chain in oyster beds for
example where algae blooms where all of
a sudden fisheries that have been
productive for generations are no longer
productive because they have algae
blooms because of what people are
spraying on their lawns so i think food
is
is something that we need to understand
is part of our our civic decision making
and that should influence our political
choices
jekyll and hyde
if someone said
i'm not going to try that
because of the name scorpion chili on
that
or that it says freakishly hot they'd be
making a mistake you enjoyed that one
very much so
can you guess why
i've tipped the hat a couple times on a
couple of sauces well maybe it's because
you kind of like the sweetness
mixed in it's got sauces yeah in other
words if you have something hot and
vinegary
to have a sweet component underneath it
or a smoky component or something else
all great food is made up of contrast
this is just super hot barbecue sauce
the barbecue sauce from hell that's how
i've described it a couple times during
the season
so i've heard you make interesting
points about how restauranteurs and
purveyors oftentimes they're selling
food at a loss because many people what
they're willing to pay for food it
doesn't exactly translate to the
economic food systems the biggest issue
in restaurant talk that isn't talked
about enough
what do you think is the disconnect
between the glamorization of food in the
united states and the price people are
willing to pay for it one of america's
greatest restaurateurs and chefs tracy
desjardins she had a restaurant called
jardiniere for 25 years in san francisco
one of america's hundred best
restaurants any of the 25 years that she
was open
she told me a really funny story she she
tried lots of ways to give money to paid
sick leave and different things for her
her employees um and one of the things
she was trying to raise prices to where
they were actually reflective of what
they were
when she opened 25 years ago her chicken
dish was like 19 bucks when she closed
it was like 23 bucks so it had gone up
four dollars
uh i think that was like you know 19 or
something like that but her you know her
rent had gone up four thousand percent
her insurance had gone up six thousand
percent see where i'm going with this so
if we can't pay
the right amount for foods when it comes
in the back door to farmers purveyors
cheese makers wine makers etc
and we can't charge what it is then the
system becomes untenable too brittle and
it collapses and i'm very very worried
about our food system because we're not
paying the right price for food we're
losing farmers by the thousands and
replacing them by the single digits and
it's going to come to a head right we've
got to start thinking about that well
i'll start thinking about it right now
you ready to move on here
this is
the bomb beyond insanity
oh my gosh
i don't like it when you make noises
like that well
this one never gets any easier
it's a moment i dread all the same
yeah that's hotter than a crack pipe on
payday
by the way it's
the chocolate milk on your
recommendation
really hitting right
now you know your staff sends out this
little questionnaire has two questions
i'm aware yeah what kind of wings do you
like
what kind of milk do you like
by the way that's still growing yeah and
burning
and it
it lacks
to me it lacks flavor yeah
i think that's my favorite producing
so much saliva yeah it's like your body
tries to defend against it or something
yeah that's why you need ice cold
chocolate milk
it's been on my training table for years
thinking back on your extensive
experience what comes to mind when you
think about the spiciest dish that
you've ever eaten in your life oh yeah
uh chili's in northern thailand
you know cost like 50 cents from a
vendor on the street there's three or
four of them you know why would you do
this to me
or
why do i do this to myself that's true
you know
that's kind of what's going through my
head right now
um
so
that is this may be the hottest hot
sauce i've ever tried
you and me both um
so
tiny tiny little hot chili in a little
village in northern thailand but i'm
thinking to myself how hot can it be
the next thing that i remember
is them pouring apparently i screamed i
mean that was
i i had an out of body experience
um
that to to date was still
the hottest
hottest uh thing that i've ever uh put
in my mouth
well i'm happy that we could pair that
conversation by the way i just swallowed
the saliva that my mouth is producing
all on its own reintroduce it
it was really odd that was that that was
hotter than some of these down there
if you
yeah
wow
[Music]
no ghost pepper
hillbilly mean
ugh well it still is gonna cool down
[Music]
whatever you know i've been a fan of
yours
and the shows for a long time until you
just had that last wing no
um
i always thought about how much fun it
would be
actually doing this with you
but if i've writ if i'd written down on
a piece of paper what i imagined it
would be like i would have undersold
myself
this is a blast you're having a good
time oh yeah
as a midwesterner myself i really relate
to the affection that you have for
culver's butter burgers i'm from
illinois
what makes culvers everything that in
and out is not to you in and out i still
think it's the most overrated
of all of the fast food hamburgers
i think their burgers are flavorless i
think things like double double animal
style literally were invented all those
off the menu hacks just to make it the
burger a little bit better
um
their fries are easily the worst fries
in the business flavorless flavorless
i know i'm gonna get a lot of letters i
do every time i mention that
but culver's does not freeze anything
right there's no frozen they freeze
their ice cream there's no frozen meat
right so it's it's all fresh tomatoes
come in there and they are cut by
someone lettuce comes in their hole and
it is cut by someone
it's a smash patty of decent beef that
comes on a buttered bun
it's not like sally's in milwaukee where
they put a dollop of whipped butter on
it you get that steak vibe steakhouse
vibe with the melted butter on the on
the crusty burger
their custard is incredible nothing gets
saved overnight it's fresh it's a
continuous feed machine there's just
soft serve coming out of it but it's
custard it's denser it's a french
custard
remarkable
some people don't like crinkle cut fries
i'm not a crinkle cut fry guy but i like
the culver's fries just good right it's
i'm there for the burger and it tastes
like beef
eating a double butter burger a thing of
fries and a 16 ounce concrete which is
what they call their their shakes or
malts
um
that's not the healthiest meal in the
world i mean certainly we shouldn't have
it's a
lot of calories a lot of fats all the
rest that we're learning we should be
healthier but if i'm going to do
something like that at a place that has
a drive through it's gonna be at a
culver's hey just keep singing that
culver's gospel and you know what those
meals
there's a place for them if they're
one thousand percent i mean i i mean i
happen to be a big shake shot i think
that's the best
one you pay a little bit more at a shake
shack but you get a better
uh quality product shake shack and
culver's i think are the best burgers in
the fast food biz
preach all right andrew zimmern
heat level 10 out of 10 puts an apollo
pepper
so the guy who made the carolina reaper
yes he is a mad scientist does lots of
the cross breeding yep and he kind of
put together you know he's apollo is one
of his frankenstein creations okay
shout out to smoking ed
all right cheers andrew what a ride it's
fantastic a thrill literally i can cross
i have very few items on my bucket list
this was one of them well i'm happy we
could do it
[Music]
good vinegar flavor
you've traveled the globe and eaten
through a cross-section of humanity's
experience with food but i know that the
comfort you have a comfort that you find
in of all things gas station pizza
so to close things out i'm just looking
you didn't i didn't detect any contempt
in your voice no over there listen we
just talked culver's i'm a midwest guy i
know about gas station pizza but i'm
curious to close things out yeah what is
your love letter to the heat lamp cooked
99 cent slice
i'm on the road
i've didn't done nothing but pound down
you know
14
ounces of you know fermented walrus anus
and some small little village in
greenland right
i get in the car i see in the distance a
red light it's the gas station
i walk in there and i need that nasty
pizza with the cheese has melted and
hardened
and never really melted again
but it's still hot enough to be food
safe and there is something
of a warm hug from like
your uncle's
third wife
who wore like really bad grandma perfume
and you're like you don't really like
hugging her at holidays and you told
your parents when you were seven i
really don't like hugging her
but when you do hug her for a brief
moment it's just one more person telling
you that they love you
and that's how i feel when i eat gas
station pizza it's like an old it's like
an old friend that tells me they love me
a nice warm hug from gas station pizza
and look at you andrew putting the wings
of death into a bear hug and choking
them out today and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
oh my gosh uh so many things uh one stop
shopping at andrew zimmern.com just go
to that top
drop down menus i've got a new sub stack
thing i'm really proud of i have a line
of spices i developed with padilla that
i'm really proud of obviously magnolia
television we do family dinner which is
a series i just love i put on my pants
one leg at a time but i'm not sure i
know someone who has as much fun as i do
life is fun
great time thank you
great job to all of you guys fantastic
as hot as that was
if it was the only hot sauce out here
and i was eating a meal
i'd be doing more of it because it has
that vinegar flavor and all the rest
i've just
that's what's great about hot sauce that
has flavors yeah you know it's like
doing drugs it's like oh my god that
bong hit was you know give me one more
exactly no i mean you just want one more
this if i never saw again it got no
flavor but i did really like some of
these things in there were just
absolutely fantastic well we're gonna
pack them up for you oh fantastic
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home hot ones boneless
chicken bites it's a party in a bag and
everyone's invited
[Music]